[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 culture du blues de
l'humour ou encore du théâtre de
nombreux rendez vous culturel vous
attendent
on voit ça tout de suite en détail dans
le sommaire le festival blues sur seine
revient pour une 21e édition du 8 au 23
novembre au programme plus de 20
concerts dans toute la vallée de la
seine des têtes d'affiché comme popa
chubby ou andré manoukian mais aussi des
talents locaux
le 6 novembre le prisme à elancourt vous
propose de faire le plan du mot avec la
quatrième édition du ces fuites humour
le concept reste le même faire découvrir
au public des jeunes pousses et des
artistes confirmés
enfin nous irons au tec à plaisir sa
directrice florence k - nous présentera
son spectacle coup de coeur qu'il ne
faut absolument pas manquer durant
quinze jours la vallée de la seine va
vivre au son du blues et des musiques
afro américaines c'est la 21e édition du
festival blues sur seine
au programme une vingtaine de concerts
sur tout le territoire
[Musique]
un mélange de country de funk et de
blues l'artiste américain peut pas le
cheville sera à conflans sainte honorine
le 8 novembre pour l'ouverture de blues
sur seine
ce festival itinérant en est à sa 21e
édition
au départ il se tenait uniquement à
mantes la jolie et s'est peu à peu
développé sur tout le territoire de la
vallée de la seine on est sur un public
voilà qui est propre blues des amoureux
du blues souvent de longue date et
étonnamment aussi un public assez jeune
qui qui revient vers ce style de plus en
plus au fil des années objectif de cette
manifestation promouvoir le blues en
proposant public des têtes d'affiché
comme paul personne le 23 novembre à
mantes la ville
non
comment le sperme et plus personne sur
qui compter
m
ou encore andré manoukian et china moses
le 22 novembre à aubergenville
ce festival est également l'occasion
pour le public de découvrir ou
redécouvrir des artistes plus jeunes il
y en a certains qui reviennent par
exemple ça râle un cas c'est une artiste
qui revient pourquoi parce que nous on à
me dire que c'est le la programmation du
public parce qu'elle était venue l'année
dernière elle avait fait un tabac et on
a eu beaucoup d'appels de gens qui
voulaient qu'on la fasse revenir chez
nous donc ouais on aime dire que c'est
la date de la date d du public il a
programmé on l'a remise la voix jazzy de
camélia jordana saura également séduire
un public plus jeune le 12 novembre à
andrésy au total blues sur seine propose
une vingtaine de concerts des
rendez-vous of dans des bars partenaires
et des actions dans les ehpad et les
établissements scolaires
du blues il y en aura également le 9
novembre à buc avec la huitième édition
de buffets de blues sur la scène du
théâtre
archi ni au coeur et le costaud cost
blues band
le concert débute à dante heures 30 le 6
novembre le prisme à elancourt vous
propose une soirée humour avec le 7-8
humour il s'agit de la quatrième édition
sur scène cinq artistes qui proposent
chacun 10 à 15 minutes de spectacle
le principe est de permettre au public
de découvrir des nouveaux talents issus
du territoire des yvelines ou de
territoire francilien elle mais aussi
des artistes confirmés
on aura alexandra pizza galy et tanoh
qui seront là dans les connu et déjà
déjà plus aboutie et puis après sur les
jeunes pousses à découvrir aussi sur
cette saison là le retour de certains
qu'on a eu la saison dernière et qui ont
marqué un petit peu les précédentes
éditions et donc on aura déjà sur ce
plateau du 6 novembre une jeune fille
dont je ne dis pas le nom qui reviendra
suite à la participation l'année
dernière et qui nous avait carrément
bluffé et toujours aux prises miles
encourus noter ce changement de date
pour le spectacle d'un don initialement
programmé le 22 novembre la
représentation a été décalée aux en 3
novembre à 20h30 plus d'informations
bien sûr sur le site qui s'affiche sur
votre écran d'autres idées de sorties à
présent avec votre rubrique ce soir on
sort à saint quentin en yvelines
il y aura du théâtre le vendredi 8
novembre à l'espace philippe noiret aux
clayes-sous-bois avec le spectacle moi
aussi je suis barbara de moore avec
nouveau spectacle d'elie semoun 7 à la
ferme du manet à montigny le bretonneux
à découvrir également le 9 novembre sur
la scène de la batterie à guyancourt le
groupe clic here
enfin le 12 novembre toujours à la
batterie de guyancourt un voyage musical
avec sherazade voici un avant-goût de ce
qui vous attend
babara je parle autrement à ta mère et
dimanche en poissons je suis bernard à
jos et dans sa rage aussi vers marare
regarde le mal que tu fais j'ai toujours
détesté les biscottes
dix ans
des mots d'amour
je coupe le bras peut-être ailleurs je
ne veux pas savoir est magique c'est
avec tout ça la cire de ma chère vous
faire pleurer s'avère moururent d'or non
mais tu parles d'une idée à la con
robert tu a gâché les plus belles années
de ma vie tu as des formes et mon corps
pour que je mette bas de nicolas et de
philippe d2 viandards deux fils
ils ont les mêmes doigts boudinés que
toi le même grosses paluches le même
regard pansin la même petite queue en
tire bouchon
maman ne vous aime pas voila je viens de
vous faire gagner de gens de
psychanalyse elle ajoute l'un d'entre
eux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
pas
[Musique]
à
elle est à présent je vous propose de
prendre la direction du tec à plaisir et
de découvrir un rendez-vous coup de
coeur celui de sa directrice florence k
- le 9 novembre
on accueille un spectacle qui a été créé
au théâtre du chêne noir à avignon ça se
joue et le malt un qui s'appelle à daawa
c'est la compagne emmanuelle manuel
cinéma qui vient de chicago aux états
unis vous allez en plus à la fin du
spectacle c'est vraiment de la
construction de films d'animation avec
des comédiens en direct donc à la fin du
spectacle ont fait monter les
spectateurs sur scène ils ont droit de
visite et ou l'envers du décor de
découvrir comment on construit un film
d'animation
il ya une vraie rencontre avec les
artistes c'est beau c'est magique
venez voir un spectacle qui vient de
chicago exprès pour pour les plaisirs on
attendre
[Musique]
oh
et
à découvrir du 5 au 7 novembre sur la
scène nationale du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une création
un narcisse il s'agirait d'un opéra sur
le rapport à l'image et la construction
de soi c'est accessible dès 10 ans à
près de l'opéra de l'opérette au théâtre
montansier à versailles c'est une
création également l'univers de yes se
déroule pendant les années folles à
paris à londres et au touquet c'est du 8
au 10 novembre
et puis un tout autre style maintenant
avec le groupe allemand zipcy nippies
qui sera sur la scène du théâtre
alexandre dumas de singe à mansle et ce
sera le jeudi 7 novembre à 20h45 le
collectif berlinois viendra notamment à
présenter son nouvel album kirschen zeit
was made in training
de 2,2
quand
[Musique]
et oui nous
on va rester quelques instants encore
dans cet esprit hippie avec une
exposition intitulée néons 77 en ce
moment au château chat noria croissy sur
seine
cette exposition retrace les premiers
pas de l'homme sur la lune en briques
lego mais vous découvrirez également une
rétrospective des jouets de l'époque un
véritable retour vers le passé est
visible jusqu'au 2 février
la grande idée de cette exposition c'est
à dire néant 70 qu'elle était
l'évènement majeur pour 70 alors 70
c'est un peu avant un peu après en 69 le
16 juillet des hommes qui ont marché sur
la lune c'était un peu un événement
majeur un rêve d'humains d'aller sur la
lune et donc du coup on s'est dit mais
que faisait des enfants à l'époque à
quoi il joue et grands parents parents
il ya déjà des marques qui sont
intergénérationnel donc ça ce qui est
super important donc on perd personne
bien au contraire on enrichit le
quotidien des enfants et puis on
on espère créer d'émotivité au travers
des yeux des parents enfin du cinéma
avec le réalisateur eric toledano venu
présenter son dernier film hors norme
dans sa ville au cirano à versailles
sortie le 23 octobre dernier ce film
coréalisé avec olivier nakache nous
plonge dans l'univers de l'autisme eric
toledano qui est l invité de l'émission
gip sur tv 78 voici un petit extrait
c'est un film qui raconte l'histoire de
deux
j'encadre ans on va dire deux patrons
d'associations qui s'occupent d'enfants
autistes qu'on appelle des cas sévères
c'est à dire des cas qui n'ont aucune
place dans aucune institution
c'est une histoire vraie qui est
l'histoire de deux personnes qu'on
fréquente depuis une vingtaine d'années
avec olivier et qui voit là ont décidé
en dehors des règles puisqu'ils ne sont
pas complètement aux normes n'ont pas
d'agrément du ministère de la santé
s'occupe des cas dont personne ne veut
et pour ce il engage des jeunes des
quartiers difficiles qui sont peu qu'ils
ont un peu des parcours accidentés sans
toujours maîtrisé
le diagnostic c'est quoi stan autisme
particulièrement sévère j'ai eu
l'assistante sociale et les mineurs elle
demandait le placement judiciaire
environ quinze jours
je trouve une solution j'imagine avec de
dire à tout le monde j'ai trouvé une
solution
tous ceux qui se trompent les
inspecteurs les gars c'est ce que c'est
l'inspection générale des affaires
sociales
c'est dans le viseur vous avez pris des
initiatives qui pose des questions nous
avons à charge de revenir à une
situation qui donne plus de sécurité
cette association répond au besoin dans
l'urgence alex et des patients que la
société refuse ou qui sont l'impossible
améliorer noter que le film hors norme
et bien sûr toujours à l'affiché dans
les salles obscures
voilà c'est la fin de ce set 8 culture
merci de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve
mardi prochain pour un nouveau numéro un
numéro d'ailleurs consacré en grande
partie aux centenaire renoir dans les
yvelines
à très bientôt
[Musique]
bon